je voulais vous montrer des petites
choses que vous nous avez donné des
trucs ce soir à l'émission du permis de
conduire sur france 4
donc je voulais revoir les photos des
permis de conduire de chacun d'entre
vous regardez la première on va le
permis de conduire sa cellule à la haye
mais elle permet je vais vous dire la
vérité l'avantagent que j'ai là dessus
c'est qu'on me l'a volé mon père me
convenir que je t'ai objets leur faire
une arme mais la bise à 27 a volé vous
les perdez colère il a 12 ans et on
dirait une grande vraiment au sérieux
une grotte
ah oui je trouve ces faits contre
l'accusé c'est vrai la saison à centre
centre hugh grant et miloudi ouais c'est
moche avait renoncé jalousie deuxième le
deuxième des médecins est sain et gérald
à eybens voulez je vous dise nakaitaci
vous va très bien bisimwa grave et vous
savez beaucoup plus que maintenant je
trouve girard idem j'ai dû la refaire
aussi une passe qui datait de soixante
huit mon père me away vas tu l'as si je
te montre la photo de la santé meyer
fait pareil parce qu'on me l'a volé
j'avais 120 milles à l'est attention
troisième regardez c'est toujours comme
ça j'ai refait aussi c'est pas trés venu
d'accord même si un chat bois et enfin
le dernier
je crois c'est tout petit nez c'est tous
les temps mais c'est quoi ça
j'ai parfait merci
elle fait des blagues mais que personne
ne peut comprendre si gilles verdez
dents mais c'est fou ça ouais
allez je vais aller couper un peu pour
la photo d'égaliser là il avait égalisé
mais le problème c'est que tu te fais
contrôler mais tu passe pas le contrôle
au minimum bien et bien le pulse et plus
choisies sur yvette
non mais c'était un esprit de liberté
voilà c'est plus que liberté là bas
serait bien mais tout cas ça vous va pas
du tout ce soir à 20h45 donc sur france
4 qui aura le permis de conduire c'est
pour ça qu'on a fait ça allait